oh hi welcome back to game life on this
week's episode we're talking skulls of
the Shogun it's a strategy game starring
Japanese feudal lords who are very angry
and very dead it's coming to Xbox Live
Windows 8 Windows Phone and Microsoft's
recently announced surface to find out
more we spoke with Jake Castle the CEO
of the developer 17 you play as
general Okimoto one of the greatest
samurai generals that's ever lived he's
betrayed on the battlefield on the eve
of his greatest victory by one of his
lieutenants and he wakes up dead in the
afterlife I finds out that he's been
screwed there by the same guy and so
you're on the sort of double revenge bit
where he's betrayed you in life and in
death and you need to break into the
afterlife basically to reclaim your
throne and gain the title of Shogun of
the Dead it's meant to be a lot easier
to play a lot more sort of just drop in
it's very arkadii me every decision we
made design-wise was meant to reinforce
this arcade influenced strategy game so
there's no menus you're not surfing
through equipping things there's no grid
it's very easy to play it's it's quick
and fast-paced and it really does feel
almost like an action version of a
strategy game so the concept behind the
17-bit studio is you know I really I
grew up playing the the classic Super
Nintendo games and intent of games I
really believe in a lot of the core
great gameplay styles of yesteryear
basically have sort of been neglected
forgotten about you know people moved on
there's a lot of really great stuff
there though that we think that we can
add you know cutting-edge artificial
intelligence to really bring back some
of those core gameplay concepts but re
explored for the modern age we've been
working closely with Microsoft on some
cool new inventions it's the first xbox
live arcade title to offer a circus
gameplay so you can take a turn send it
to your friend and sort of move on it
and do something else
we offer cross compatibility this will
be the first game from Microsoft Studios
- you can play on the phone versus
somebody asynchronously on Windows 8
versus somebody on Xbox Live Arcade you
know play between different games you
can play different turns kind of like a
lot of the you know common and iOS games
stuff like that these days
and we also feature play and resume
where you can like play on the bus you
can be playing through the campaign get
home turn on your xbox live and
back into the campaign right where you
left off so Microsoft is putting a lot
of effort into the surface and Windows 8
it's kind of a new direction for them we
think it's gonna be very exciting it
worked out well for us we had already
worked on that you know on the Xbox Live
Arcade version of it and their phone
versions we had some touch stuff going
so the the surface you know offer is
basically any input device you like like
we've got it running on on PC with
keyboard and mouse you can play like
that if that's comfortable for you you
can play it as a tablet game because
you've got you know beautiful touch
controls or you can play it with a USB
controller or plugged in and play it
like a console game so it really kind of
offers every kind of gameplay you could
imagine really skulls of the Shogun will
be sipping on three platforms the phone
the tablet and on Xbox Live Arcade
around the launch of Windows 8 this fall
sometime ok well Jake thank you very
much for being here today no problem for
having me yeah no not at all and I have
to say this this new diet plan of yours
it's really working out great for me
fantastic yeah no I'm ready to put on a
bathing suit again this is excellent I
think is my fibula showing I think it is
anyway goodbye see you next time